cars are integral to the way that people
live their lives today we use cars for
taking our kids to school we use our
cars for commuting to work but when we
look at cars today they're fundamentally
disconnected vehicles people don't want
to check their phones at the door when
they get behind the wheel so we
partnered with auto manufacturers and
technology partners to figure out the
best way to bring Android into the car
today we're announcing Android auto
which extends the Android platform into
the car Android auto combines the best
of both worlds you get the connected
apps and services on your smartphone
with the physical controls that were
optimized for driving in your car we had
to go back to the drawing board and
really take an experience that was
designed for a smartphone and break it
down to its bare essentials we focus it
down to the features that the user
really needs within the driving space
we've made Google Maps really easy to
use for the car we've got nice easy to
access touch targets and a simplified
interface the voice technology that
we're using within the car is super
conversational your hands are on the
wheel you know your eyes are on the road
set a reminder to get gas on the way
back to work pick up my dry-cleaning
remind me to get tickets on the way home
Google brings you just the right
information at just the right time so
when you set reminders while you're
driving your phone will remind you later
on even if you're outside the car
Android developers will soon be able to
create entirely new experiences for the
car we're really excited about this
opportunity because for us this is
really very much at the beginning and
you know we're really gonna go on a long
journey with this
you